despite more than 130 mass shootings
this year any change to our gun laws is
still a tough sell on Capitol Hill
yesterday that led to multiple
confrontations between Democrats who are
urging action and Republicans who are
not New York Democrat Jamal Bowman and
Kentucky Republican Thomas Massey
clashed outside the house chamber
of their freaking cowards
I'm talking about gun violence
tool that allows teachers to care oh my
God
to protect that's one and here's Georgia
Republican Marjorie Taylor green and
Florida Democrat Jared Moskowitz she
wants to arm the teachers in this
country so if you want to have a good
talk about schools and protecting
children we need to talk about
protecting our children the same way we
protect our President we protect our
celebrities we protect reclaiming our
time oh there are six people that are
dead in that school including three
children because you guys got rid of the
assault weapons ban
because you guys made it easy for people
who don't deserve to have weapons
hmm